so this is probably gonna be the
shortest explained video that I've ever
put out in the history of my youtube
channel or that I will ever probably put
out again because this is simply just
the answer to one question the question
everybody's been asking since the
initial introduction and the aftermath
of original sin who is this all new
version of Thor is it Ross Solomon is it
Valkyrie is it enchantress everybody
wants to know well ladies and gentlemen
this was revealed to us at the end of
this story when it turns out that none
other than Jane Foster is wielding the
hammer of four now here's the question
how is it that Jane Foster can wield the
hammer of four if Jane Foster has cancer
well again we've discussed this
previously and this is an established
concept there's a precedence for this
there's a precedence in the sense that
when Thor was first cast out of Asgard
and he was sense of the planet Earth he
was put into the body of a handicapped
man named Donald Blake whenever he
wielded the hammer of Thor his handicap
went away but whenever he lost the
hammer of Thor whenever he reverted back
to its to its walking-stick then Donald
Blake basically began limping again that
was the entire basis for this so the
precedent exists now the question is
what are we gonna see from this point
going forward will we ever see this
version of Thor again we don't really
know but the fact remains that at this
moment right now Jane Foster has
officially been revealed by Jason Aaron
to be the wielder of Thor's hammer when
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace